qu'at-il qu'est ce donc
mais qu'at-il prévu pour la 10ème
ouverture de ce calendrier de l'avent de
youtube de fabien olicard alimentaire du
linge de trucs plutôt court parfois et
des fois on sait pas ce que c'est mais
en tout cas c'est des trucs qu'ils
aiment et bonjour à tous le peuple d
internet
je vous est prévu aujourd'hui toutes les
énigmes oui parce que sur cette chaîne
en elle des énigmes et vous a souvent on
n'aime pas quand ça nous prend trop la
tête mais on n'aime pas quand c'est trop
facile c'est la difficulté du truc
j'ai beaucoup aimé ceux ci que l'on m'a
offert et la personne qui l'a offert
c'est que j'aime bien les énigmes et que
du coup j'en connais beaucoup et bien là
le format est un peu sympa s'appelle
allumé denim aux e mails anonymes de
nicolas sarkozy qui mute et devienne de
danse est fourni avec une boîte
d'allumettes qui sont des allumettes
sécurité père ne s'allume auront pas
moche mais j'ai peur quand même utiliser
un peu de mémoire erronée j'ai eu un
fils est salée mais il n'y a pas de
soufre donc ça risque rien et 12 l'avez
deviné dedans il ya comme son nom
l'indiqué une cinquantaine des limes à
résoudre à l'aide d'allumettes et ben je
sais pas pour vous mais moi je reconnais
quelques-unes avec des allumettes
toujours les mêmes qu'on connaît depuis
tout petit ou deux qu'on a appris en
plus encore notre vie mais c'est la
première fois que j'en vois autant et
qu'elle veut mettre qu'elle me met à mal
la les cartons à 107,20 côté bening de
l'autre côté la solution donc faut
résister à la tentation de retour en
être trop vite la carte
il n'ya jamais dans go et spéciale de
style la solution serait de casser les
allumettes il s'agit jamais cassé les
allumettes
il ya juste à chaque fois la logique a
trouvé ça peut être parfois des
opérations mathématiques style en
chiffres romains il faut déplacer les
allumettes pour composer deux
quand chiffres romains ça peut être des
constructions de carré ça peut être des
changements de forme ça c'est par
exemple à un poulet qui regardent d'un
côté et à vous et en bougeant seulement
deux allumettes il faut qu'il regarde de
l'autre côté
donc après il ya des fois des
interprétations là par exemple pour
celle ci j'ai bien galéré pour qu'ils
regardent vraiment de l'autre côté mais
je pensais à une symétrie dans ma tête
mais l'énoncé ne dis pas qu'il faut que
ce soit ainsi mais il faut juste qu'il
regarde de l'autre côté c'est une piste
vous pouvez chercher un indice en bas de
votre écran un bouton like où tu peux
appuyer
c'est un indice ne s'est loupé ce que je
peux faire voilà je trouve ça très
original c'est simple vous en parle
trois heures parce que parce que sinon
je vais vous dévoiler les lignes qui à
l'intérieur et c'est cool j'ai un petit
reproche à faire à ce jeu parce que
j'allais voir plein de prix sur amazon
même si c'était un cadeau qu'on m'avait
fait pour voir le prix et j'ai vu que ça
coûtait 25 euros je trouve ça un petit
peu cher que ce soit 50 centimes d'euro
l'énigme et si vous demandez ça en
cadeau à quelqu'un
peut-être que enfin j'en sais trop rien
wen jeudi le prix je trouve ça vraiment
cool je trouve ça un poil sur côté au
niveau du tarif c'est tout par contre
pour un budget moins cher vous ai trouvé
un autre truc assez drôle qui à moins de
sept euros
c'est un calendrier d'énigmes c'est une
bonne idée ou pas vous avez peut-être eu
vent et de mon canapé dans certaines
vidéos vous avez vu un calendrier de
citations et d'explications d'expression
est bien là ce sera aux claviers pour
les prochaines ou cinq jours correspond
à une énigme et le lendemain on a la
réponse de l'énigme de la veille
c'est first qui fait ça et 365 et nîmes
pour moins de 7 euros
j'ai feuilleté un petit peu quand même
parce que je n'ai pas pu m'en empêcher
on en a qui sont assez simples et il y
en a que je connaissais pas du tout eu
par exemple compliqué c'est celle du 28
mars
c'est un oubli mois l'énigme c'est 31
octobre égale 25 décembre et la question
à quelle époque de l'humanité cette
égalité at-elle été vérifiée un indice
il est dans le titre the posies ça je
vous donnais juste 1 à 10 pour ceux qui
aiment vraiment les nombres et les
chiffres il ya un rapport avec
l'hôpital et le décimales bienvenue dans
ce live
je pense que si vous appréciez de près
ou de loin les énigmes mais plutôt comme
un petit divertissement une petite
énigme à picorer temps en temps je pense
que ces trucs là peuvent vraiment vous
plaire puisqu'il n'ont plus alors que je
reconnais pas mal comme d'habitude
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en
l'air cette vidéo depuis de vous abonner
s'est pas encore fait vous pouvez aussi
me mettre des idées d'autres trucs denim
dans les commentaires et moi je vous dis
demain rendez-vous mais voudront mettrai
dans l'autre sens c'est maître yoda qui
a parlé
[Musique]
il
oui